ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt meine lieben freunde und eine liebe
freunde ihr seht schon das läuft
irgendwie gerade nicht so ab wie alle
anderen minecraft folgen mit luca hier
denn das problem habe ich ja bereits
meiner instagram story geschildert die
aufnahme war beschädigt ich habe diese
episode die hier gerade seht aufgenommen
vor 3 stunden und da die episode
zweieinhalb stunden lang ging das waren
nämlich dass der baum einer strandhaus
villa modernes haus mäßig das ging auf
jeden fall sehr lang und deswegen hat
irgendwie meine kamera zum ende hin
faxen gemacht und die komplette face cam
datei war beschädigt ich habe sie
versucht mit verschiedenen programmen in
die richtung handbrake frame versucht
wieder herzustellen ist war mir nicht
möglich
von daher habe ich jetzt gedacht hey
schneide ich das ganze video doch
einfach ohne face cam
er ist mir allerdings relativ schnell im
schnitt aufgefallen nach 12 minuten man
das funktioniert nicht und dafür steht
auch dieses projekt nicht ich arbeite so
viel mit meinem gesicht mit gestik mimik
wer nicht cool zum anschauen gewesen
dann habe ich mir gedacht ich hab doch
noch ein spielstand von der mep bevor
ich das ganze video gestartet habe
spiele ich einfach nochmal hab das dann
probiert und dann ist mir relativ
schnell aufgefallen wenn ich jetzt mache
ich genau das gleiche was schon gemacht
habe es ging wie auch nicht so spaßig
und deswegen habe ich mir jetzt gedacht
bevor das alles für die katz war und
bevor ich jetzt irgendwie schlecht drauf
bin und heute keine folge kommt spiele
ich euch das hier einfach in 1000
prozentiger geschwindigkeit ab ihr seht
ja schon hier das ist eine krasse teil
ich befinde mich gerade stimmen da sehe
ich hier gerade und kommentier einfach
ein bisschen was ich hier mache hier
gehe ich zum beispiel gerade wieder in
die festung rein beziehungsweise baut
mich erst mal dort hoch weil ich dort
quad sehe und das ist auch der generelle
grund warum ich in den keller gegangen
wenn in der heutigen episode
beziehungsweise direkt sogar zu beginn
der heutigen episode einfach und quarz
zu farmen ich habe dort nichts neues
entdeckt ich bin noch mal kurz in die
festung eingegangen dass ich dir jetzt
jeden moment bezieht er sich erst mal
ganz kurz hoch sehe dann allerdings
relativ schnell dass dort kein platz ist
laufe dann ein bisschen durch die
festung durch besiegten passt lette
besiegten halonen routen gleich noch
fang an zu brennen sterbephase qantas-
für geschmack trifft mit lukas da hab
sogar ein gas getroffen und den dann
auch noch besiegt mit dem pfeil und
bogen und habe auf jeden fall hier im
netz eine menge quartz abgebaut
insgesamt glaube ich fast 26
es ist ein zehntel von denen von der
spec anzahl was ich benötige für die
strandvilla damit nämlich ein paar
inspirationen mal wieder auf youtube
geholt da findet man ja wirklich
wahnsinnig viele coole videos zum thema
minecraft und haben möchte eine coole
moderne strandvilla bauen
das war das ziel der heutigen episode
seht ihr auch im titel eingeblendet und
ich kann mich noch mal entschuldigen es
tut mir leid dass das jetzt gerade so
eine etwas andere folge ist ich habe
mich die ganze zeit schon gefragt hey
luca episoden gehen immer mindestens
eineinhalb stunden in den raw aufnahmen
dann passiert der erste fehler dann ist
es das erste mal so dass in die
videodatei beschädigt ist heute ist der
tag folge 33 oder so wir haben lange
durchgehalten und heute zum ersten
episode die nichts was die anderen hier
zum beispiel treffe ich gerade wieder
einen zombie der da irgendwie mit
spielen auf mich geworfen hat er
allerdings leider kein dreizack du mich
fallen lassen
hier ist man immer den wasserfall ein
bisschen kaputt gegangen habe ich
versucht zu reparieren aber nicht so
richtig hingekriegt bei einem bulli bin
dann habe ich mich jetzt hier ein
bisschen vorbereitet und so ein bisschen
meine sachen sortiert denn für die
strandvilla was er habe ich ja schon
gesagt im titel sieht und was auch der
eigentliche sind ja heute gibt so da
braucht mir eine menge schwarze blöcke
allerdings keine normalen quarz blöcke
sondern glatte quartz blöcke das heißt
ich musste alle blöcke die ich im netter
mir zusammen gesammelt habe erst mal in
den ofen backen
in der zeit wo die geschmolzen sind habe
ich nicht an allerdings weiterhin
vorbereitet für die strandvilla für den
bau der strandvilla habe mir zum
beispiel laub mitgenommen glos down und
bin jetzt einfach ein bisschen über
meine insel getigert um nach
tintenfischen zu suchen wir zum beispiel
baue ich gerade mit der behutsamkeit
spitzhacke in paragraph blöcke ab wie
ich ja benötige um dort hinten das gras
so richtig hin zu bringen auf die insel
und ich schaue ich jetzt hier weiterhin
nach tintenfischen um die ich dann
irgendwann später auch gefunden habe
allerdings musste ich diese tintenfische
töten
meine lieben freunde eine kurze
schrecksekunde für die fünf getöteten
tintenfische ihr fragt euch
wahrscheinlich ein luca warum musstest
du diese tintenfische töten ganz einfach
ich brauchte inc sex also tintenfisch
beugt bild intel keine ahnung ist genau
heißt um mir rauen trocken beton zu
machen dass wir nicht unter die
kommentare geschrieben dass das deutlich
geiler sei als wolle und keramik für
irgendwelche bauten hier vorne zb sehe
ich jetzt sogar die ersten fische tötet
die hier gerade und hat dann sogar
direkt meine acht tintenfisch beutel
zusammen sammeln können
die zusammen mit weißem farbstoff den
man durch biel bekommt im crafting table
einfach zusammengepackt ergibt einen
grauen farbstoff den habe ich dann mit
kies und erde kies und sand zusammen
getan habe ich den beton bekommen
ich habe ich mir ein paar antriebs
schienen noch leben getrachtet weil die
ich ja immer noch darauf warten musste
das werk fast zuende schmilzt so dass
wir den die glatten graz blöcke bekommen
und die antriebs schienen seht ihr auch
jetzt sofort werde ich jetzt noch nicht
dahin setzen kann was ich mache
ich habe mir schon mal die karte geholt
die sätze ich jetzt auf jeden fall hier
in die antriebs schienen und dann seht
ihr schon wie das ablaufen wird wenn wir
daran herfahren werden und das
strandhaus soll halt hier vorne stehen
nicht da da soll ein wasserfall haus
dann habe ich dann geplant sondern
direkt an der bissspuren unserer idee
spur
denn ich hab mir gedacht das ist macht
am meisten sinn wenn quasi vom pool des
strandhauses hin die komplette sonne
gesehen wird also ich finde man ein ganz
cooler aus richtung wenn man irgendwo
und das eigentlich immer so süd west
ausrichtung wenn man hat sonnenuntergang
und den sonnen höchststand und deswegen
wollte ich so auch den pool hin bauen
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht dass ich
die strandhaus silla doch nicht auf die
insel setzte die sich hin neben unserer
insel befindet wo wir auch damals in
einer der ersten folgen den schatz
gefunden haben
piratenschiff sondern mir dafür auch
wieder eine eigene insel bauer und dann
haben wir quasi überall ganz viele
verschiedene inseln auf jeder insel
steht was dann haben wir zum beispiel
die strand weder die ich hier gerade
bauen auf einer anderen insel haben wir
dann das wasser ballhaus was sich in der
folge eigentlich angekündigt habe wo er
leider die base camp dateien nicht mehr
funktioniert hat auf einer anderen insel
haben wir dann den leuchtturm hier zum
beispiel bin ich erst mal eben schlafen
gegangen auf unserer stadt insel und das
soll ja auch so ein bisschen der sinn
des projektes sein dass wir halt überall
verschiedene inseln haben und da immer
so hin und her fahren können über
seerosenblätter laufen können und so
weiter und so fort hier vorne
pharmig gerade noch ein bisschen erde
die benötige ich nämlich wie ich vorhin
schon oft genug gesagt habe
für die insel die setzt sich jetzt auch
gleich vorne mal hin und zwar erstmal
hier vorne denn dort kommt der beton hin
dass seht ihr auch gleich sofort da
schaue ich jetzt mal ganz kurz weil ich
hatte mir das natürlich in meiner test
welt wieder so ein bisschen
aufgezeichnet wie ich das alles haben
möchte da nämlich dem beton hingesetzt
habe ich das sogar an einer stelle ganz
kurz verbaut
ihr seht doch schon das material von dem
beton sind jetzt gerade noch nicht so
schön aus so sieht er sowieso ein
bläulicher kies das liegt nicht daran
dass man trocken beton in minecraft
immer so ein bisschen mit wasser
behandeln muss seht ihr schon hole ich
mir hier gerade platzierte drauf und
dann verwandelt sich der trocken beton
zu normalen beton und die textur
bedeutet nicht china und das bildet so
ein bisschen die säulen artige stütze
für das erste obergeschoss von unserer
strand weder die wird nämlich nicht nur
ein stockwerk hoch sondern zwei
stockwerke das obere stockwerk so ein
bisschen rüber und wird angehalten von
diesen betonsäulen hier gleich euch das
alles noch mal ein bisschen wie das sein
soll hier tatsächlich ein bisschen
klostern laubblätter drüber und so ein
bisschen gras damit alles so ein
bisschen klein aussieht und auch noch so
ein bisschen
natürlich allerdings gehe ich jetzt auch
schlafengehen nochmal ganz kurz rüber
beziehungsweise die ampel jetzt sofort
auch auf was wirklich hier noch an ihr
jetzt erstmal auch an die wände hoch bzw
einfach mit dem restlichen quarz den ich
noch hatte weil wir brauchen wirklich
ganz ganz ganz ganz viel spaß also in
der nächsten episode die morgen auch
schon hat wiedergutmachung online geht
weil es heute ja nicht so richtig
geklappt hat mit der face camp werden
wir auch wieder eine menge meinen gehen
wir werden in die hölle geht noch ganz
viel platz holen und jetzt seht ihr auch
ganz kurz wenn ich mich nochmal hier
kurz auf meine erhöhung darauf bauen
dass das ganze so später aussehen wird
also da kommt die strandvilla hin mit
dem pool war sie zu unserer stadt
wilhelm rechts seht ihr den weg von der
bahnschiene dort rüber da kann man dann
einfach die sie rüber jumpen und die
drei türme mit dem trocken beton
signalisieren einfach hey darauf steht
quasi das erste obergeschoss ja das war
jetzt eine ganz komische episode ich
habe gerade acht minuten einfach durch
kommentiert was ich gemacht habe
es tut mir unfassbar leid ich weiß nicht
wo der fehler liegt ob ich irgendwas
falsch eingestellt habe oder und das
vermute ich es sieht einfach wirklich
daran dass die maßnahme zweieinhalb
stunden gingen ich habe kein mal
irgendwie gestoppt ich habe gedacht die
kamera kriegt das hin habe es allerdings
wurde eines besseren belehrt und hab es
die kamera doch nicht hingekriegt
von daher meine lieben freunde ich kann
es verstehen wenn man der heutigen
episode und daumen runter gibt ich bin
selbst nicht so zufrieden mit ihr
ich war mega extrem zufrieden nach der
aufnahme direkt allerdings da war es mir
einfach nicht möglich jetzt die normale
die sonne hier raus zu hauen von daher
wie bereits gesagt morgen um 20 uhr
kommt eine neue episode online dort wird
hoffentlich alles wieder normal klappen
denn ihr die folge nicht verpassen
wollte dann abonniert der main kanal
unter dem video werde schon einseitig
dennoch die glocke dann bekommt ihr eine
benachrichtigung sobald neues video
online geht und wir sehen uns morgen um
20 uhr wieder bei dem zweiten teil
unserer strandvilla che
[Musik]